hello everybody and welcome to another
moneymaking guide today I'm going to be
showing you how I made over 530k uh just
by playing about 10 minutes um once
again this is going to be by flipping uh
if you don't know anything about
flipping I will have a beginner's guide
and my Advanced guide Linked In the
description uh but it's really easy and
what we're going to go over is just uh
seven or eight items that you can use
every day to um flip for a very healthy
amount of profit and that are consistent
in and you can do them every 4 hours if
you want or just once a day and I made
about
530k okay let's get
started okay guys so we have 40 mil um
we're going to see how much we can
actually get in just a couple minutes
here um so we're going to show you some
other items let's start uh with the
Cannonball works pretty well the Canon
base cannon ball again these are all
just items you can easily do flip for a
solid amount of profit uh so we're
buying them for
2011 and let's have a look here
not bad uh 3 GP is not awful limit on
that is
7,000 uh next uh let's try the adamant
Dart adamant
dirt there we go uh so we're going to
buy them for
157 and I sell them for
152 that is 50k I think on there limit
is $1 ,000 I think uh mind you I'm not
looking at any graphs or anything I'm
literally just going to toss these
offers in sure sometimes you might lose
some money but um the majority of the
times you're going to come on top um so
Oak planks we can try too another pretty
highly traded item
486 and 477 yeah sure screw it let's put
it in there uh Oak planks I'm not 100%
sure what the limit does on that let's
just do 10K um bottom four
529 and we'll sell them
for 504 yeah that's super good for the
mahogan logs
price and just tossing 10K don't
remember what the limit does on that
look all the cannonballs are already
through um next do the soul runes
something I didn't do last time works
pretty nicely
actually uh 149 and we'll set
for 142 yeah that's 7K or 70k will make
on
that uh pop it in for 10,000 of
them and uh next uh try regular planks
maybe uh 331 I think it was
into
303 or 3 11 I that's still decent and
uh yeah I don't know probably around
10K and 262 pretty classic but still
Easy Money 10K right
there and for the last item yeah Dragon
Bone's pretty decent that but I'll buy
them for
3120 and we'll do like 7K dragon
bones yes 6K all right we use up all our
money and uh there we go 5 minutes in
game time and we'll come back when uh we
bought all the stuff okay we're back and
we pretty much bought everything uh
barring the dragon bones so we only
ended up using half our cash stack um
but I guess we'll just hit
collect bam and we got to cancel all
these offers
unfortunately uh we hit the buying limit
so we uh sold I bought most of them but
not quite all mahogany logs we didn't
quite get all of them but we got the
Grand majority so it's not a huge deal
and yeah we won't be able to check the
margin so I'm going to use a separate
account just to double check what we're
at uh so
cannonballs looks like we can sell them
for
204 uh so that is a 6 GP margin on
cannonballs okay adamant darts we can
sell for 156 it looks like uh so uh 40K
profit on that not bad Popp in for
156 uh what's next Oak planks looks like
uh we can sell Oak planks for
486 um which that's actually quite
nice Oak planks
486 uh next we have regular
planks put an offer into buy and it
looks like we buy them for
315 and we bomb for 303 again quite a
nice profit on that planks
315 um mogy logs I'm kind of excited to
see how much we get on these hog any
logs we bought them for 504 and we can
sell them for
528 pretty nice
actually 528 we'll to see if these
actually go through or not but it seems
pretty
promising um nature runes probably only
got a one or two G margin on Nunes but
we'll double check again looks like
Nunes actually went down one GP so we'll
see if we can just dump them back for
what we got them for which is 262 and
the last item is the soul
Rune uh we bought it
for 142 and it looks like we can sell it
for only
143 uh not not a huge profit but still
10K and yeah looks like some of the
items are already coming through and
we'll come back when we've actually
managed to sell all the items okay guys
we are back and we sold everything and
for the price we originally put in uh
the most profitable item I think is the
mahogan logs uh but the planks did
really well the darts and the
cannonballs uh the runes being kind of
mediocre okay uh so the cannonballs we
got a seven or six GP margin on and 7K
of those gives us 42k in profit uh the
adamant
darts uh gave us four GP each and got
11,000
darts um the oak planks gave us 400 um
we sold them for
486 and N9 GP in profit gives us 90k so
not bad uh the regular plank planks we
got 12 GP on and 10K of those again
gives us 120k in profit the mahogany
logs we sold for a 24 GP margin so very
good on the logs and we got about 9k of
those giv Us 224k in profit uh the
nature we broke even on and the Soul
Rune we just got a 1GB margin on giving
us
10K um so here's everything we sold it
for and yeah let's see how much we got
in total uh very easy I only took 10
minutes of my time and uh we'll pop in
our cash deck and see how much we made
so it looks like 530k in about 10
minutes work uh even the dragon modes
you didn't really need at all cuz
obviously I didn't buy any of them uh
but even these eight items very easy to
do or seven I guess um very easy to do
they they flip very quickly like this
they took like half an hour to 40
minutes to buy uh majority of them I
wait a little bit longer just to buy
like the full amount but I had 99% of
them after half an hour and they sold
relatively quickly as well and that's it
guys that's how I made about 530k with
only 10 minutes of work you can do this
every day these items buy and sell very
quickly they work very well for flipping
I hope you guys enjoyed if you did uh
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button to stay up to with my more recent
videos and I'll see you guys next time
[Music]